merci monsieur le Président
ma question s'adresse au ministre de
l'éducation nationale monsieur le
ministre dans le calendrier
révolutionnaire nous sommes en pluvioses
c'est le mois de la pluie et il pleut
des annonces de fermeture de classe
partout dans le pays surtout en zone
rurale alors avec 59 milliards de budget
6 et demi pour cent de haut on ne peut
que déplorer ses coupes sombres
2000 postes en moins certes la
démographie scolaire connaît une baisse
continue certes cette revalorisation
enfin ce budget conséquent permettra une
revalorisation indispensable des
rémunérations des enseignants mais alors
que tous les classements internationaux
toutes les évaluations nationales alerte
sur la fragilisation de du niveau global
des élèves alors que vous vantez les
vertus des effectifs réduits et des
classes dédoublées où est la cohérence
pédagogique et surtout où est la quand à
quelques kilomètres quelques hectomètres
parfois ici on va fermer une classe
parce qu'avec 22 gamins ils sont trop
nombreux et à côté on va se réjouir
d'avoir 12 gamins dans une classe
dédoublée pour plus d'efficacité je le
rappelle 70 % des élèves qui relèvent de
l'éducation prioritaire se trouve en
zone rurale ou dans des quartiers qui ne
sont pas concernés monsieur le ministre
ma question elle est simple la ruralité
est-elle devenue la variable
d'ajustement de vos politiques
éducatives
[Applaudissements]